конкретних дат cool та українці зможуть
їздити цю Європу без віз уб'ю селина
називають за 1 україну перебуваючи на етапі
ви до неї технічних критеріїв беремо
дивуй єврокомісії ремонт місія
дроти не рубає у брюсселі прийнято в
рот животи arcanum of the scene кулерах
кісп одягаюсь а ще тим не матами
символічного значення, що вигляд україни
нагорі народжуються і до 15 цього грудня у
хвалять позитивне рішення ще до
лібералізації візового режиму проти та
рішень з цестусу у цьому й чує
технічних передумавши шляхом разів
підпорядковується закону дачі процедур до
сідниці прикольно ось україни члени з у
своєї на dynasty з досі молдови ти
можеш зайняти Європу за словами і
доступності глави мзс у лінії сер каліка
у довезу та переговори європейці
позитивну синю київ україна
в ікону you plan de ne moya зараз
претензії для України ще харчування та ким
ми maemo завершити та завершать та мама та
моя до броні антикорупційного прокурора
так і завершіть процедуру по
національному агентству залякування
корупції c також сайт і чекати на крем то
виймає піддавайтеся вона ти законниками
були прийняти і верховну раду як так
званий безвізовий пакет в одному з
примітка в руку міс синій прийменники
карта Європи вона закінчується на чад
читанням україни маємо бельгійський експорт
українського харчування нба леал
не пов'язують зв'язки став про нього до Києва
чи нагороду шукаю Європі за раз тенденції
до посил і не курей донів вони дали
паралізувати футбол моделі не далеко не
ідеальна година для прийняття такого
рішення та іскри зад біженців вкрай
праві партії на підйомі
теж як що буде вирішено на дати
безвізовий режим України багата
європейських політиків побоїться ще
даних не проголосують на доступних
виборах в тім, що заповнює
безвізовий режим з українською тазі місцеві
європейських кордоном ціна прим він не
повезу не процес їм легше україна ви
кунаї nike льодовик критерії та візи ска
пхають за 2 тисячі європейці на дадуть свої
черевики заробляють і вигляд поведінка 6 9